this episode is sponsored by google play
with the help of legends of runeterra
[Music]
in a world where the only thing worse
than a movie tie-in video game is a
video game tie-in movie everything sega
studios will wait sega studios
slow your roll a sonic movie is one
thing but what's next Ecco the Dolphin
Streets of Rage actually that sounds
pretty rad I'm in Sega's Studios will
crack the game movie code by making it
Star a quick furry animal making them a
cop or partnering them up with one and
okay I'll say it making a faster bluer
version of Detective Pikachu hey
wouldn't be a sega project if they
weren't riffing on something Nintendo
did first Sonic the Hedgehog made some
[Applause]
bad I want to think on you hear me God
who close call me Sonic the Hedgehog uh
not at all horrifying creature he'll
start a movie so nice they made it twice
because for the first time in internet
history and angry mob of nerds actually
made something better no matter how much
pain and sweat it took for the animators
to hit the release date man that must've
cost a fortune I wonder where they found
the money apartments for rent I found on
Zillow and they Olive Garden because
when you're there make is a mellow
yellow' please call optical illusions
tell her I need new frames
have you tried their never ending pasta
bowl it never ends well all these
product placements and they didn't do
the one that would actually fit this is
how you Sonic the sonic you've always
known his back which if you're just a
casual fan means he's fast and he
collects rings let's get fast nailed it
but if you got sucked in to all the
other sonic media you're gonna have to
be satisfied with a chili dog joke here
and there that's awful what did you eat
I think it's called a chili dog while
those of us in the erotic Sonic fan our
community had to make do with a bare
minimum you got ignores forever follow
along with your hero as he hides in a
cave for an entire decade spying on
everyone in town like the penny wise of
Montana but when he's discovered after
playing with himself a little
too hard he'll have to run to safety and
the only thing standing in his way
is that he never shuts up and definitely
needs to go on medication I'm blending
in like a boss stop talking no you stop
talking be quite something you'll be
quiet sonic sonic one a big tank 0zi
flossing
he's flossing isn't he Sonic's not the
only relic of the 90s along for the
adventure
there's also Jim Carrey because everyone
knows he's the guy to call when you need
to track down a rare animal and
protecting Sonic all the while is James
Marsden the only actor charming enough
to film a whole movie with this creepy
blue statue he's done being America's
second Hospital I don't have to convince
my fiancee and she should be are you in
love with him this time he's ditching
his wife for a hedgehog as they set off
on an unforgettable drive across the
Pacific Northwest yep a movie about a
character whose defining trait is how
fast they move and they stick him on a
20-hour ride to San Francisco gotta go
for 90 minutes or we don't have a movie
so enjoy what's actually a very fun kids
picture even though it let's say
liberally borrows from a certain quick
silvery x-man what but they dangle
enough tails and Robotnik stache at the
end to make you excited for the next one
unless they work in the music that plays
when Sonic is running out of air in
which case I will have a panic attack
[Music]
story lightning mcqueen james marsden
friend to cartoon animals everywhere
federal marshal bill doctor does little
and stop or my mom will hoot reanimate
her sure toilet paper was all fun and
games when they shot this but today this
is considered an act of terrorism did
you see how much toilet paper the next
person that goes into that bathroom will
have nothing to wipe with did you know
all the Olive Garden plugs in Sainik
were the writers idea check out this Q&A
with sonic screenwriter Pat Casey plus
get some details from the potential
sequel it's a new interactive series
called hey fandom where the creative
minds behind your favorite films and
shows will answer your dumb questions
and it's on support of Direct Relief
providing protective equipment to
medical professionals during the
pandemic now show some gratitude for the
real heroes by clicking the link in the
description below this episode is
sponsored by google play get legends of
runeterra and discover more on google
play
I'm never gonna financially recover from
this if you water water
it grows nothing is impossible and I do
nothing every day bazinga